jeffrey jeffrey b
sauce jeffrey basis multi-billionaire
worth
208 billion 208
that's 208 too many man for those of you
that haven't
checked out jeffrey went to space
recently
[Applause]
they call it the first human flight i
don't get it are they saying astronauts
aren't humans uh rude they went in what
of course looks like a giant schnob a
schnitzel
an abba rooney no wonder in the
development process
there to look jeffree bases in the eye
and say jeffrey hi
the rocket's great but it looks like a
dog can we
i don't like uh making fun of people's
appearance but he looks like he's about
to snap at any point
i get it i wouldn't want to confront
this man and say his billion dollar
rocket
what actually so yeah jeffrey basis
super rich
but have you ever heard jeffrey bezos
laugh
it's worth all the 108 billions
[Laughter]
[Music]
tell me that's not a super villain laugh
you can
[Music]
[Laughter]
you'll notice it changes
exponentially along with his network
and then disclosure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's also a compilation of him getting
bald just saying
anyway have you seen that clip where jim
carrey jokes about how his wealth has
changed him
it's it's so fitting for what i just
showed you it's a bit of pressure
i noticed that it changes you in little
ways like it's changed the way i laugh
at parties
oh really i used to go i used to go
that's really funny
you know now i go oh
beautiful
it's funny because it's true anyway
we're not here to talk about jeffrey
base's laugh for an hour
so yeah he went to space and there was a
bit of controversy
because he uh he thanked the customers
and the employees
we're making a dent in it and we
appreciate you
uh for allowing us to be part of your
town
and uh and then i also i want to thank
uh every amazon employee
and every amazon customer because you
guys paid for all this
so i like how everyone's laughing
uncomfortably so yeah this
uh people weren't happy about this
because amazon has historically not
treated their
employees very good to say the least
in the middle of pandemics he even
cut people's wages when he didn't need
to
uh but did no one hear him he said
thanks
hello is everyone missing this why is
everyone so mad he said thank you
ungrateful some people can't take
a simple thank you hello so
the i forgot to mention this but the
plan for blue origin which they state
is that this sort of space travel they
literally go up to
like they go to where the line is of
here's space
and you float there for like 60 seconds
and then you go down
and then you can tell all your rich
friends all about how amazing this
experience was
so their plan is to commercialize this
and
the plan is to try and make it a promise
of space to all
doubt i doubt it that is not happening
we're just gonna hear celebrities and
rich people tweet about
how wonderful it was and how the earth
is so beautiful and we need to protect
it
as i saw it there in all its beauty or
you'll see some unfunny
jokes about how the earth is not flat at
all
you dummies i was there that's the
projection of the next five years you're
welcome
and second of all am i the only one that
don't care like i
don't care about going above the earth
so high that it counts as space so i can
say i went to space i don't get it
if i went for free i still wouldn't do
it i don't care i can't be the only one
everyone's like space is the coolest
thing ever it's so cool i want to be out
it's cool to try and understand it but
we don't have to leave
necessarily the earth to do that so
right now we have elo musk
epic richard branson branson uh
also doing a space program jeffrey bases
doing the space program so we have three
at least three billions working on space
programs what do they know
right what do they know about the earth
that we don't
how how [ __ ] are we all right so
richest man on the planet he goes to
space
what else does he do with his money you
might ask well i found this out recently
he's building i don't know why i don't
get it
but he's inside a giant rock inside the
middle of nowhere
he's building a giant clock
which the engineering and engineering
skill to build this
is uh amazing it's supposed to last for
10 000 years
and the problem with a clock is that
they will automatically
offset its time as it keeps going so
it's hard to make them accurate and if
you do
such a long span of time like 10 000
years
it's a really difficult feat it has this
sort of built-in self-correcting system
that uses the sunlight and yeah yeah
there's a legend of zelda reference in
the clock okay now i like it
that's epic okay but how do i tell what
time it is
i'm not mad about it i'm just confused
i will say something i like about bezos
is that he's a fellow hater of apple
not for the same reason but he hates
them we're happy to sell
competitive products on amazon we do it
all day
we you know we sell nest thermostats we
do
we sell apple tvs on amazon do we okay
i don't know the number one whatever
thing that people are doing on their
ipad right now if you look at the
rankings
they're playing a game called angry
birds where you throw birds at pigs and
the pigs blow up the number one thing
that people are doing their kindle right
now
is reading steve larsen you look at
tablet swedish writer by the way big uh
jeffrey base is just a booga booga meme
all apple users
hi stop playing angry birds you infidels
you scum something i noticed and i
wanted to find out while making this
video
was why do people hate amazon so much
like people despise
amazon and people hate bezos with a
passion
a lot of people do at least so i looked
up criticism for amazon and
holy sh there's a lot to break down here
a lot and i'm not gonna because that'll
take forever
uh i think the one of the big things is
them not paying
taxes and you probably heard this a lot
of times as well there was a bunch of
big news saying
amazon isn't paying taxes pay your taxes
pay your taxes
from what i understand the the way they
could pay such low taxes was that they
run
ran the company for a loss for a long
period of time
so they were able to cover that cost of
what they lost
in paying less taxes and normally i
would say something like well
don't hate the player you should hate
the system you know if they have these
rules
they should really change them because
obviously people are going to take
advantage of them especially a company
like amazon but
it seems like a fair thing right
government helping
new company startups maybe there should
be a limit on on the money in the future
or something i don't know to adjust for
it but i can't really hate on that
uh there are other tax practices that
you could say you scum me though i'm not
trying to just
brush over that another way they paid
less taxes is they offer
their employees shares which you know
what
i'm sure the people who work for amazon
dagger shares are very thrilled about
that
at least i'd be i think shares are up
like 87
since the panemic which is how he got so
ungodly rich
which is kind of stuff if you think
about it like the people that benefited
from the panemic were the billionaires
and the middle class and lower class are
all that paying for it
like how does that make any sense but
you know what that's how it goes
i think to me out of all the stuff that
amazon
has been i mean maybe there's more and i
don't know about it but
what i responded to the most was how
they treat their workers so poorly
i was kind of shocked by some of the
stories that came out
i especially enjoyed this leaked
document that came out very recently
uh from amazon logistics this evening an
associate
discovered human pieces in an amazon bag
that was returned to the station by a
driver diaz cannot
must not return bags to station with
poop inside
thank you thank you amazon they can
afford to
i don't know work for the gas station i
don't know it's something
so at least people aren't forced to take
[ __ ] in bags okay
that seems like the bottom line uh worse
than that is how they used to have
employees working in suffocating heat
110 degrees people were reportedly
passed out and had to
take an ambulance this is of course to
say money that's the bottom line
it became a big scandal when this news
came out and they corrected it
after but i think it says a lot that it
took a scandal to adjust something like
this
and if you don't believe that the
treated workers poorly i think their
burnout rate
kind of speaks for itself they were
losing about three percent of
its hourly associated each week the
normal percentage of turnover rate is 12
to and 20 and anything below 10 is
considered good
but amazon is roughly 150
so at this rate there's concern that
amazon would not be able to replace that
as quickly as staff is leaving which is
kind of insane
but if you think about it it makes sense
they were trying to replace everyone
with robots anyway
they in the future they won't have to
worry about it they got the long-term
plan for all these issues
[Music]
another really funny story i love this
uh
this was uh oh it was earlier this year
amazon
ran these ads having workers talking
about how they don't want to unionize
so that workers will not have more
rights we at the birmingham team
have a great leadership we really don't
need anyone coming in and
telling us what they want to give us
because basically
we have everything we need here always
want it to work for amazon this is the
who says that who says that working for
a multi-billion
trillion dollar conglomerate no i'm fine
i don't need i don't need anyone to help
me get me more no
no thank you like that's why that's why
they're losing
so many employees because everyone just
loves it that's why
i mean the stats speak for themselves
i'm sure some people enjoy it but i
found funny and odd about this is that
they ran the ads on twitch
which is owned by amazon
they're trying so desperately to stop uh
amazon workers from unionizing
which is so crazy that they're running
these [ __ ] ads
i'm just interested in it and i wanted
to look into it and here i am sharing
what i found hope you enjoyed it
i'm not a hater on you know rich people
or them spending money on whatever they
want because space is cool i get it
don't have a problem with it i just
don't care i think what's most
concerning is you know these
multi-trillion dollar conglomerates
changing our culture
uh monitoring our culture censoring our
culture
just gaining too much power and it's
such a strong force that it's inevitably
here
and it's here to say we and we really
are powerless
almost in having to say if we want it or
not but hey i mean it takes away the
awkward
awkwardness of going to a store so hey
all right i'll keep shopping that's it
for this video hope you enjoyed if you
did smash like and i'll see you guys
tomorrow brofist
you thought it was gay but true
relevance
never really died welcome to the first
undead game use any item in your
inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there
stickers our emotions memes our emotions
express your emotions with me
them for likes share them for love get
up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this